new information has come out that
America has profited massively from the
north stream pipeline sabotage that it
vehemently denied it had any part in
doing you remember the north stream
pipeline sabotage right when the
pipelines that deliver natural gas from
Russia to Europe were blown up and all
of mainstream media claimed that it was
Putin that did it and that even the
slightest idea that America was involved
somehow was Russian propaganda even
though America's got to benefit the most
from it now for the long run you simply
want to change the structure of energy
dependence tonight sabotage at Sea
that's what President Biden is calling
the leaks and explosions on the
Nordstrom pipelines Russia is most
likely behind this the United States had
nothing to do with it it's just Russian
propaganda and disinformation well if
you don't remember any of that that's
okay because that was by Design because
since that pivotal point in the war
there has been a media blackout on the
subjects
none of them dare speak about it and for
good reason because if they did Cover
the story they would have to admit that
America's profited massively enormously
since the pipeline was sabotaged by
Putin the UK prime minister Rishi
sunaki's voice to make a gas deal
announcement with the United States
after the cup 27 climate Summit the head
of Germany is saying they're going to
need massive amounts more liquefied
natural gas to fill that gap which I
guess is good news for America I don't
think the word saving Europe or the
phrase saving Europe is too strong
America is cashing in on the suffering
of their European allies right now and
in this video we're going to expose all
of it
foreign
if you happen to run an online store or
an e-commerce business and you're
looking to save more time and money with
shipping then you have to check out
shipstation shipstation is hands down
the best way to ship because it allows
you to automate and streamline your
entire shipping process while saving you
up to 84 from Top carriers like UPS USPS
and DHL Express over 130 000 Merchants
use shipstation and 98 of companies that
use shipstation for a year end up using
it for life you can connect to almost
any selling Channel you can think of
they've got scam-based workflows bulk
updates and automation processes to ship
your orders super fast you can compare
race and then print labels and batches
and shipstation will even instant update
the tracking information to the selling
Channel and the customer wants an order
ships you'll even get free comprehensive
onboarding support to get you shipping
faster right away and you can get
started by going to shipstation.com for
a 60-day free trial that's two months of
Cheaper simpler shipping completely for
free go to shiftstation.com with the
link below right now thanks to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
after the attack Germany Sweden and
Denmark all launched independent
investigations to find out who was
behind it and after weeks of gathering
evidence Sweden lands on something
massive so massive that Sweden
absolutely refused to share any of its
findings with anyone for reasons of
National Security according to Swedish
investigators quote the confidentiality
level of the results of this
investigation was too high to share them
with other states end quotes hmm the
results of this investigation are too
confidential to share with anyone what
does that mean they found out who did it
but they refused to share it with anyone
this was an act of War it's one of the
greatest environmental disasters of
recent times we need to know but the
answer is too confidential for us if
they found out it was Russia would
Russia be too confidential to share with
the world well no the world hates Putin
right now everyone and their mom is
looking for a reason to condemn him if
they found evidence that Russia was
behind the attack like everyone had
claimed wouldn't they happily announce
that to the world but they didn't so it
most likely could not have been Russia
maybe Sweden is hiding it because the
answer makes them look bad somehow or
maybe the attack was done by a different
Nation a nation's so powerful a nation
that has so much influence over Sweden
that Sweden wouldn't dare snitch on them
[Music]
this is the Rand Corporation no not that
ran Corporation this rant Corporation
the Rand Corporation is in fact not a
corporation it's a non-profit a
non-profit funded by the Secretary of
Defense it's funded by the US Army the
Air Force the Department of Homeland
Security and more and their purpose
they're a thing tank created in 1948 to
give public policy suggestions to the
U.S armed forces in other words there
are a research arm of the government
armed with hundreds of millions of
dollars tasked with the job of
researching how to best direct the U.S
war machine and in 2019 they publish a
little-known report called extending
Russia competing from advantageous
ground and this report was very
revealing some might even say it read
like a prophecy and in it it gets a long
list of options for how to best exploit
quote Russia's economic political and
Military vulnerabilities and anxieties
and
basically a how-to guide on how to take
down Russia and many of the top
recommendations in that report are
chilling it says that the best ways to
crypto Russia are not through taking
them head-on in war but through economic
means and the best ways to do that quote
hinder petroleum exports of Russia or
that America should reduce natural gas
exports of Russia or to hinder pipeline
expansions of Russia it literally says
quote a first step would involve
stopping North stream 2 end quotes and
quote a second option is to encourage
new pipelines from other gas resources
End quotes what other gas resources
might that be America of course and
other countries America has influence
over like Australia the problem was at
the time the U.S couldn't act on many of
these recommendations Europe had become
hooked on cheap Russian natural gas they
weren't gonna give it up just to serve
America's interests nor stream 2 was
already under construction at the time
with Germany and Germany was determined
to complete it so Europe's dependency on
cheap Russian natural s didn't look like
it would be slowing down anytime soon
both the Obama and Trump administrations
even tried to stop the Nordstrom 2
construction through economic sanctions
but to no avail this made Germany angry
claiming that the US was trying to quote
Meadow with European markets End quotes
but you know what would make the
Europeans think twice about buying
Russian natural gas if Russia were to
invade another European country quote
significantly deeper economic sanctions
would likely extend Russia economically
but the success would be limited unless
other countries joined in however in the
absence of expanded Russian aggression
abroad in the absence of expanded
Russian aggression abroad the United
States would have difficulty persuading
other countries to take extra measures
against Russia such as shutting down
Financial transactions End quotes So the
U.S wanted the EU to stop being so
dependent on Russian gas but now we need
to have tougher sanctions and I'm afraid
at some point this is going to probably
have to involve oil and gas the Russian
enemy is vulnerable eighty percent of
Russian exports are in oil gas and
minerals people say well the Europeans
will run out of energy well the Russians
will run out of cash before the
Europeans run out of energy and I
understand that it's uncomfortable to
have an effect on business ties in this
way but this is one of the few
instruments that we have to over the
long run you simply want to change the
structure of energy dependence but in
the absence of expanded Russian
aggression abroad that wasn't going to
happen so all America needed to do was
wait for some Russian aggression abroad
once that happened the blueprint was
simple
foreign
step one according to the random report
is after you get some Russian aggression
abroad you want to quote provide lethal
support to Ukraine End quotes quote
expanding U.S assistance to Ukraine
including late though military
assistance would likely increase the
cost to Russia in both blood and
treasure End quotes after all the US has
had a history of supporting Russia's
opponents in Ukraine and Syria before
the report even amidst that quote proxy
competition of the sort is not new End
quotes the report did discuss other ways
the U.S could put military pressure on
Russia but Ukraine was given the most
consideration and while the report
warned it wasn't guaranteed the work
enticing Russia into a proxy war was a
Surefire way to drain Putin of his
resources and to make a villain of the
Russian government among the Russian
people and around the world so after the
U.S kept building up NATO military power
in Ukraine after they just kept fueling
the fire between Ukraine and Putin
that's exactly what happened Russia told
the US to back off the U.S told Russia
no chance and just a few weeks later
they invaded if Russia invades that
means tanks are troops Crossing the the
border of Ukraine again then there will
be uh we there will be no longer on
North stream too if we we will bring an
end to it if Russia invades Ukraine one
way or another Nordstrom two will not
move forward at first it looked like the
economic sanctions were getting the us
would have wanted they even convinced
Germany to cancel the opening of
Nordstrom too even though this was
something Germany did not want to do at
all but as the month went by things
started to unravel many countries
continue to do business with Russia and
Western Europe underestimated just how
much it was addicted to Russian energy
exports so one Russia shut off their gas
supply via North stream 1 and civil
unrest exploded in Europe and looked
like peace negotiations were inevitable
this was bad for the us if peace
negotiations happened then the sanctions
will end nor stream one will come back
online and worse no stream 2 would be
finished and officially open for
business this will make all the effort
and resources the US had poured into
Ukraine a waste meanwhile Putin wanted
the pipelines to reopen there are not
many ways Russia makes money a lot of
their wealth a lot of the funding for
the war in Ukraine comes from energy two
weeks before the pipelines exploded
Putin even said that all Europe had to
do was drop their sanctions turned on
your stream too and Russia would
continue to supply their natural gas
Germany was even in talks with Russia
about reopening the pipelines on the day
the pipelines were attacked but then it
happened tonight sabotage at Sea that's
what President Biden is calling the
leaks and explosions on the Nordstrom
pipelines all the potential peace stock
all that potential de-escalation all the
potential Russian guests to Europe it
all went spewing out into the ocean and
America was right then and there waiting
to plunder
[Music]
pretty it's a tremendous opportunity to
once and for all remove the dependence
on Russian energy since the sabotage the
US has already made deals with the EU
and the UK to double America's natural
gas exports to these countries and the
mainstream media is applauding the US
for this and again I don't think the
word saving Europe or the phrase saving
Europe is too strong Becky because
without U.S imported natural gas Europe
would be in a far more dire situation ah
yes saving Europe that's exactly what
we're doing so after all these years of
desperately trying to stop Nordstrom and
desperately trying to weaken Russia
economically to change the structure of
energy dependence in Europe the US has
finally gotten what it wanted and it
happened almost exactly to the T
compared to what America has blatantly
said out loud in the past with regard to
nordstream 2
we continue to have a very strong and
clear conversations with our German
allies and I want to be clear with you
today if Russia invades Ukraine one way
or another nordstream 2 will not move
forward and America is cashing in
America is charging European nations
quote almost four times as high as the
same fuel cost in America End quotes but
I mean come on supply and demand quote
the fact is if you look at it soberly
the country that has most profiting from
this war is the us because they are
selling more gas at higher prices and
because they are selling more weapons
End quotes one senior European official
said many European officials are now
wondering if they were wrong to blame
Russia for the north stream attacks and
that quote there is no evidence at this
point that Russia was behind the
sabotage End quotes instead of one
European official echoing the assessment
of 23 diplomatic and intelligence
officials in nine countries interviewed
in recent Weeks end quotes and as more
and more European people have taken to
the streets to protest the economic
crisis members of European leadership
are getting antsy accusing the US of War
profiteering through extortion and
weapon sales but like many other
classified secrets we may never get the
real answer until 50 75 years from now
when all those in power today are dead
and there's no one left to blame I for
the life of me don't understand why the
EU doesn't want to know who did it this
is a disgrace what is wrong with us this
is an unbelievable destructive out and
we don't want to know who did it is it
because we know the answer or is it
because it's the wrong answer
contrary to popular belief America's
First Choice is almost never wore just
like the situation in Ukraine right now
it's a proxy war America doesn't like
getting their hands dirty themselves
America gives money and weapons to
Ukraine so they can do it for America
but before the proxy wars before the hot
Wars America would much rather conquer
nations with an even subtler method a
method that enslaves the target Nation
without them ever even realizing that
they're enslaved before is too late and
that method is financial slavery
shackling countries in debt forcing them
to open their doors to American
factories American sweatshops two
American companies to extract all their
natural resources this is how America
conquered the world this is how America
became the modern day Roman Empire not
through messy expensive risky hot Wars
that aren't scalable but they're the
most subtle and effective form of
imperialism the world has ever known and
the most successful corporations are no
different in order to scale to the size
of a Fortune 500 company you need some
kind of slave labor whether that be Dirt
Cheap factories in China or child labor
for chocolate in Africa what do you
think all the truly ethically sourced
responsible sustainable brands are
always these tiny tiny companies that
charge way more than big corporations
because you physically can't scale
without Financial slave labor the most
powerful people in the world got to
their position of wealth and power
because they mastered the secret of
financial slavery see what most people
don't understand is that slavery never
went away it just changed forms and no
one noticed that's because the elites
have worked very hard to keep it that
way but not anymore see after years of
researching these videos I knew I had to
expose all of it so I spent the last six
months putting together my greatest body
of work yets Financial slavery Master
Class 20 plus lessons all narrated by me
in these same addictive documentary
style format you've come to love all
centered around exposing this
fundamental secret and how you can use
it to gain more money and power for
yourself without being as evil as them
I'm really proud of this masterclass I
can say with confidence that this is
something you're not going to learn
anywhere else and you are gonna love it
so scroll down click the link below and
watch the first lesson for free right
now and on top of all the game changing
knowledge You're Gonna Learn I wanted
this to be a chest for you to make money
right away too so by joining you can
earn around a hundred dollars for every
person you refer to the masterclass and
on top of that I also provide
step-by-step instructions on how to take
clips of my videos edit them into tick
tocks and YouTube shorts so that you can
go viral and get sales like what Andrew
Tate did with his Affiliates or some of
them were making crazy amounts of money
like eleven thousand dollars a week but
he only paid his Affiliates 25 per sign
up we're paying you around a hundred
dollars per sign up so scroll down click
the link below and buy now
foreign